في جلسه نقاش ضمن منتدى شنكريلا للامن
والدفاعي في سنغافوره قال وزير الدفاع
الامريكي ان المحادثات مع الصين ضروريه
للحد من امكانيه اندلاع نزاع وعبر اوستن
عن قلق بلاده من عدم استعداد الصين
للمشاركه في اليات افضل لاداره الازمات
على الصعيد العسكري وفق قوله
[موسيقى]
اننا لا نسعى الى نزاع او مواجهه مثل ما
لا نرضى ان نفضح للترهيب وهنا اشير الى ان
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بصدق بمبدا الصين
الوحيده والحفاظ على الوضع الراهن بمضيق
تايوان وستظل تعارض بحزم اي تغييرات
احاديه الجانب بغض النظر عن الطرف الذي
يقف وراءها
الصراع ليس وشيكا او حتميا والردع الحالي
قوي ولقد قالها الرئيس بايدن بكل وضوح ان
الولايات المتحده لا تسعى الى حرب ذريه
وانها مع ضروره ابقاء قنوات الاتصال
مفتوحه مع الصين ولا سيما بين القاده
العسكريين
فكلما تحدث بعضنا الى بعض تجنبنا سوء
التقدير وسوء التفاهم اللذين قد يقوداننا
الى ازمه او نزاع